announcing a major war on freedom of
speech and really actually demonstrates
that there's a greater agenda going on
here a massive war on masculinity
because Andrew is empowering men to take
personal responsibility he actually
teaches them how to leave the system how
to leave the Matrix how to become an
entrepreneur how to live the night of
Life how to basically save yourself
because nobody is coming to save you how
to become immune from all of this
corruption that we saw and the Tyranny
that we saw over the last two years you
believe in his right to speak is this a
watershed moment here as bad as people
rally around one of his most viewed
videos on YouTube is actually how to
fight depression without any
pharmaceutical pills which will
basically leave you like a dead zombie
all of this stuff empowers men so of
course he's being de-platforms in casual
because ultimately the system the powers
that be they want men in particular to
be weak fat and compliant because who is
it that fights the Tyranny it's the men
it's the men that fight and it's the men
that go to war so of course they
canceled Andrew